at this altitude I can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start
shaking you know I also your personal
question no it is
I'm a cybernetic organism living tissue
over metal endoskeleton this episode is
brought to you by 99designs 99designs is
the global creative platform that makes
it easy for designers and clients to
work together from logos to apps and
packaging to books 99designs is the
go-to design resource for any budget
I've used 99 designs for many many years
now I've used them for book covers for
instance mock-ups for the 4-hour body
which went on to become a number one New
York Times bestseller illustrations for
my multi-volume The Tao of Seneca and
other graphic design projects and I've
been really impressed by the quality of
their designers and the designs that
I've ended up using most recently I use
99 designs to update the illustrations
and layouts of my five morning rituals
eBook this covers my most consistent
morning routines and rituals and I offer
that as an incentive for people to sign
up for my newsletter so this is a PDF
bonus that acts as a carrot to increase
the number of email subscribers the
illustrations inside are gorgeous and I
loved working with the designer who we
selected for the project so you can
check it out take a look at that at 99
designs com forward slash Tim that's the
number 99 designs com forward slash Tim
and you can see exactly what I'm talking
about with a real world example of what
has come out of work with them none DNN
designs designer search tool connects
you directly with one designer based on
a design category or an industry
specialization style skill level
availability and more so you can really
check all the boxes that you need and
see who matches up or you can start a
contest and that means you invite the
entire community to take a shot at your
project then you pick your favorite
right now you guys my listeners that is
can receive a free $99 upgrade on your
first design contest so check it out
to see what it looks like to get your
first free upgrade please visit 99
designs com4 mush Tim and click on the
link in the
landing page so again check it out
99designs dot-com forward slash Tim I
get asked all the time if you could only
use one supplement what would it be and
my answer is inevitably athletic greens
it is your all-in-one nutritional
insurance I recommended it in the 4-hour
body did not get paid for that and I
travel with it to avoid getting sick I
take it in the mornings to ensure
optimal performance it just covers all
my bases if I can't get what I need
through whole food meals throughout the
rest of the day if you want to give
athletic greens to try they are offering
a free 20 count travel pack for
first-time users I always travel with at
least three or four of these this
represents a $100 value so if you buy
athletic greens you get an extra $100
and free product so check it out
athletic greens calm forward-slash tim
again that's athletic greens calm
forward-slash tim for your free travel
pack with any purchase
why hello my beautiful little munchkins
this is timber's and welcome to another
episode of the tim ferriss show where it
is my job each episode to tease out the
habits routines favorite books life
lessons and so on of world-class
performers across every possible
discipline and my guest today is Patrick
Collison co ll is o n at Patrick C on
Twitter
Patrick Allison calm Striped calm
Patrick is CEO and co-founder of stripe
a technology company that builds
economic infrastructure for the internet
we'll explain what that means in this
episode after experiencing firsthand how
difficult it was to set up an online
business Patrick and his brother John
started stripe in 2010 their goal was to
make accepting payments on the internet
simpler and more inclusive and the
stories fascinating because in part
there were many incumbents people
thought stripe had no chance it was not
intrinsically interesting to a lot of
the people who might have assessed it
and yet today striped Powers millions of
online businesses around the world and
is worth roughly 20 billion dollars
making the brothers two of the youngest
multi billionaires on the planet
prior to stripe Patrick co-founded
automatic which was acquired by live
current media for five million in March
2008 in 2016 he was named a presidential
ambassador for global entrepreneurship
at President Obama originally from
Limerick Ireland Patrick now lives in
the San Francisco where stripe is
headquartered and I thought I'd mention
just a few of his favorite books because
he is one of the best read humans I've
ever encountered and that's saying a lot
he has read I would have to imagine
thousands of books and I did some
filtering and searching and found a
number of them that he considers
particularly great in his words and I'm
gonna just list a few and then I will
put these in the show notes at Tim da
blog forward slash podcast the first is
the rise and fall of American growth and
that's my dog whining the background the
second is a novel mind-body problem
that's a - mind-body problem poor
Charlie's Almanac which has come up a
lot on this podcast by Charlie Munger
and something incredibly wonderful
happens subtitle Frank Oppenheimer and
the world he made up there are many many
more I'm going to put those in the show
notes for you guys and filter them for
only the particularly great and you can
find those at tim blog forward slash
podcast and just search patrick and
it'll pop right up so without further
ado please enjoy this wide-ranging
conversation with Patrick Collison
Patrick welcome to the show thank you so
much for having me I am thrilled to
connect to finally have this long-form
conversation and I thought a good place
to start might be by quoting from a text
exchange or rather one of the first
texts that I got from our mutual friend
Chris Sacca has also been on the podcast
for those who don't know him extremely
adept investor an all-around hilarious
guy his minute he's a real character his
real character it's managed to make one
or two or however many billions of
dollars which is amazing because I got
to see him from the early days when you
probably first met him I guess maybe a
year to later in any case Chris is a
character and he very rarely makes
introductions he very rarely proposes
introductions so I pay attention when he
does and he sent me as context of course
I was familiar with stripe
I had heard your name before we had I
think even exchanged potentially a
couple of DMS on Twitter right but he
said and I'm gonna edit here for length
a little bit but Patrick is quite
literally one of the smartest people
I've ever known
like he puts Larry Page on his heel
smart I don't know anyone who has one
read more books and two has a near
photographic memory for what he has read
his thoughts are provocative and
challenged the status quo his success is
no accident and then then you can fact
check this when we when we get into more
of a conversation here but plus his
origin story is great as I recall : grew
up in rural Ireland took his first
communion money and bought a computer
created his own operating system while
coding over a dial-up line Paul Graham
for those people who don't know the name
and basically the Yoda of something
called Y Combinator come back to that
Paul Graham noticed him and invited him
to the u.s. I met him
when he was 15 and PG that's program
brought him by the Google offices pretty
sure he dropped out of Harvard or MIT
etc etc he's also a pilot who when Obama
made the trip to Cuba invited along a
few top entrepreneurs like the Airbnb
founders Patrick said he would meet them
there and rented a small plane to fly
himself from Florida okay pause now
Chris and I were also exchanging text
messages earlier today because I wanted
to ask his permission to to read that
and there are two more things I'll add
as background-color and then we can we
can get amongst it so the first he says
quick story automatic and we can get
into that but this is this is one of
your previous companies was a front-end
on eBay that allowed sellers to upload a
bunch of products at once and scale
their operations one night someone from
the Netherlands wrote them an email that
automatic didn't support Dutch literally
in the middle of the night they wrote
back something like fifteen or thirty
minutes later saying quote it does now
end quote and then this is a very Sokka
esque expression [ __ ] legends period
and then he said also when we sold their
first company I held a little closing
celebration at that bar below my house
as then plays district this is in San
Francisco well they were both underage
but Patrick's brother John got negged
from the bar literally could not get
into his own celebration for selling a
company becoming a millionaire oh and
never forget at that moment it
crystallized quote what's happening out
here is different there's no hierarchy
predicated on seniority smart young
people who bust their asses don't have
to quote work their way up and quote so
that is all by means of of introduction
yeah I think we should probably just end
the podcast right now because any
possible way that any human alive today
or who's ever existed in human history
could possibly live up to that yeah it's
good to say no pressure nothing to live
up to now but I think we can we can
start with very comfortable ground and
then it's books let's talk about books
you have many books I want to say 600 or
more in the recommended reading section
on your website maybe I'm getting it
wrong maybe it's been changed and you've
you've categorized them you have some in
above average you have others as labeled
per tick
literally great and it was range this is
from quoting from a wired article in the
UK but they range from imperialism to
engineering democracy on and on and on
what makes a book particularly great and
which of those do you end up
recommending the most or gifting the
most other people hmm I think well I
find personally actually that it really
matters a lot sort of when I read a book
instead of the frame of mind that I mean
at the time I sort of when I stumble
across it and often I'll kind of start a
book you know at some point and maybe
revisit it sort of months or in some
cases even years later and find that it
has kind of a completely sort of you
know renewed resonance or significant or
something and so I think there's kind of
a you know Chris and Marc Andreessen and
others talk about this idea and of
course maybe at this point talk about a
sort of product market fish and founder
market fish I think with books there's
really something around a sort of reader
book fit and the kind of particulars of
that moment and so in just by way of
example I've been thinking a whole lot
of late about sort of the importance of
kind of cultural capital and how it is
that people choose what to do and to
aspire to and focus on and try to make
happen in the world and the degree to
which they're willing to take risks and
the importance of visions and the
importance of mentors and people to look
up to and all that anyway and kind of
specifically the idea that you know
perhaps in the kind of a first half the
Tran century or maybe the first two
thirds of the 20th century there were
kind of lots of examples of that and
perhaps I mean I'm not sure whether this
is the case or not but maybe perhaps
through a few of those today
thinking about this of late and of
course I'm not the first to point this
out or raise this as an issue but I
stumbled upon just a couple of days ago
a book published by I'm probably gonna
get the name wrong but the there's a
Center at ASU it's like the the Center
for science and possibility or some
I'm pretty sure I'm getting that name
wrong but but it's along those lines and
they actually published a book of
science fiction written by well I guess
a whole host of authors with a foreword
from from Neil Stevenson about exactly
this idea the importance of optimistic
visions and kind of science fiction as
sort of flagging points on the horizon
that might be interesting directions to
sort of try to paddle towards so anyway
I think that for books yeah I mean this
kind of matching of kind of your mindset
and kind of what's important to you at
the particular moment with the kind of
content itself sort of really matters I
think a corollary of that is that it's
actually valuable to sort of to I at
least found it useful so sort of to buy
a lot of books that sort of seemed
interesting in high quality but before
I'm necessarily ready to read them at
that moment and maybe I'll kind of read
the beginning or a couple chapters or
something but you know not really kind
of commit to finishing it and you know I
I'll leave it out around the house like
there's books on the bookshelves as
books on the kitchen table those books
you know beside the couch these books in
my bedroom there's usually books on my
bed and so on and you know it's kind of
in your mental landscape and I often
find I guess that kind of six months
later or 18 months later something
happens something you're reminded of
something and you realize oh man I
really should get back to whatever book
it is I was just going to say if if it's
helpful I was going to ask about the
dream machine hmm yes and maybe that
illustrates how you vet books or hold on
to books that are particularly valuable
because at any given point in time even
if you have 60 books around your house
there are hundreds of thousands of books
published every other right so there's
yes there's a selection challenge yes
okay well so first off I think you
should mostly ignore the books that are
published every year and take advantage
of the fact that
you know quite a lot of books been
published say you know up to ten years
ago but books published up to ten years
ago people have had a lot of time to
kind of filter through them and sort of
try to select the you know the real gem
is there and of course they're all the
false negatives like there were a lot of
great books that just never for whatever
reason got the attention they kind of
deserved or maybe that the sort of they
don't of the salience they ought to have
for you but but I really think people
should be kind of much more biased
towards older books than they are I
think the dream machine is a good
example of this and I think there were
kind of two things I guess that stand
out in the dream machine the first is
Mitchell waldrop the author he really
spent the time well I should describe
what it is it is a book about the
history while it is nominally a
biography of JCR Licklider and and you
know many people were responsible for
the creation of the Internet
but I think Licklider has more claim
than any other single person to being
the individual kind of causally
responsible for its creation he funded a
lot of the early researchers he sort of
tried to bring the community together
and he really kind of instigated much of
the movement that that led to ARPANET
and the internet and so on and and this
amazing book about obviously one of
those important inventions in the
history of humanity
and Mitchell Waldrop spent the time to
sort of real I mean years to really
understand in depth not just kind of the
specific sequence of events that led to
this happening but the kind of milieu
and sort of intellectual environment and
thinking and landscape that it all came
from and so the book starts way before
Lickliter was doing anything because
there were kind of all these different
kind of feels and disciplines and sort
of strains of thinking that leaked that
are built on I think it's a you know
pretty rare that an author either takes
the time or has the time and to to kind
of really go deep in that matter and
it's striking that if you look at sort
of how the dream machine came to be he
was he was funded by a grant as I recall
it was the sloan Foundation I could be
wrong on that but I believe was the
sloan Foundation
you know that they thought this was I
mean obviously kind of a super important
period in history but sort of you know
Waldrop was not on sort of toiling under
the clock to get a book out by Christmas
he you know he was really trying to sort
of to capture an important series of
events in in the arc of Technology
so that's really what stands out about
that book how did you come across that
book because what was it in print or out
of print at the time that you came
across it it was it was out of print
there were a couple of copies on Amazon
and I after I finished it I was so
excited about it that I went and bought
a whole bunch of them to give away to
people at stripe to give away my friends
and you know fairly quickly we exhausted
Amazon's pretty limited supply I think I
I first heard about it from I think some
combination of Brett Victor and Alan Kay
Alan Kay you know many of your listeners
well-read know about for anyone who
doesn't he was a researcher who worked
at he was kind of best known for working
at Xerox PARC with this amazing
Industrial Research Lab that it was kind
of played as a formative role in the
creation of the GUI the graphical
computer interface and ether Nash the
kind of one of the main networking
technologies an object-oriented
programming which is kind of the main
programming part onyx used today and so
they were just like really critical in
kind of the history of you know what we
consider modern technology modern
software hey Alan Kay worked there and
was one of the kind of leading you know
researchers there and then Brett Victor
is one of the most interesting kind of
researchers and software I don't know a
creatives working today and and I
remember Alan saying that the dream
machine is the kind of is semi unique
among kind of Computer History and
Technology history books in and they're
really kind of gets it right and also
you know we're a pretty young field and
so there hasn't been a whole lot of kind
of research and
you know deep scholarly scrutiny at
least the extent that there might be for
I don't know math or physics or
something but but this book I really
stood out and you know the technology
industry is not an industry that sort of
spends a lot of time looking to its past
in a way that I think is really both a
strength and a weakness in that you know
people are always trying ideas that it
fails kind of tons of times before and
they're kind of oblivious to the fact
they've failed tens of times before and
that that really is kind of a good thing
because sometimes you know the fact that
it has failed five times before does not
mean that it's going to fail the sixth
time but it you know can of course also
in some ways be a weakness we don't kind
of build on ideas that precede us Allen
Kay's line about this is computer
science is a kind of pop culture where
it's sort of this kind of Brownian
motion rather than kind of really
building layer by layer and so in that
broader culture I think the dream
machine is kind of an outlier and you
mentioned Allen I
I should I should I will just mention a
quote that perhaps people have heard
which is is often misattributed but it
is I think correctly attributed to Allen
which is the best way to predict the
future is to invent it yes there may be
a quote that that people recognize but
perhaps not in association with the name
yeah yeah Alan I would say is I mean
kind of quite widely recognized as as a
genius but kind of despite that I think
he is still kind of underrated I think
he I think he will be even more highly
regarded in 50 years or in a hundred
years than he is today you are you're a
young guy what is your age currently I'm
thirty thirty Wow time for testing what
time to odd order a walker on Amazon for
him if you are a student of history you
mentioned something in relation to
assessing books that has popped up in my
homework or it's a research rather for
this conversation and that is that
perhaps one shouldn't overweight with a
recency bias the books published in the
last year
you should give books a chance to fail
or percent
in a sense and feel free to correct me
if I'm getting this wrong but I've also
read that you if you've talked about how
it is risky for people to emulate the so
the companies deserve those startups
companies around them that are
contemporaries that are doing well and
that writes it it seems like you have
made more of a study of the greats
in the earlier days of the valley or by
extension companies like Microsoft where
the outcomes are more unknown could you
talk about that a bit and yes I may
perhaps some of the things that you've
gleaned or any lessons that have stuck
with you and dig into perhaps some of
the conclusions you came to even if
temporarily after studying these greats
and one example which which may or may
not be a good example but what came up
in doing some reading for this is that
you observed that Google Facebook Amazon
were created with conventional org
charts in in in in some respects so why
so you question to the value please
correct me or elaborate on this the
value of innovating in that particular
capacity because there would sir and
that now I'm laying on my interpretation
of that which is there there are
potential unknown risks in doing so and
yeah right the sort of questionable
upside in throwing more unknown
variables into something like that
versus other places where you could
focus so could you could you could you
expand on that and then right share any
other conclusions or lessons that you
that you came to well I think the kind
of general idea here behind this is I
think people often conflate to the
question of sort of what it would be
good to see others do versus what you
should do yourself and kind of what I
specifically mean is people have tried a
lot of different kind of organizational
structures and methodologies over time
right and and of course you know while
in
Rod's strokes many things have remained
the same in terms of maybe some of the
characteristics required for leadership
or the importance or you know - which
makes kind of a human satisfied in the
work around sort of having kind of the
opportunity to have autonomy and to kind
of build mastery and and having a kind
of mission they believe and so on so the
lots of things remain the same there has
been kind of some evolution and that you
know organizations you know Google today
say does not look especially like maybe
IBM of 1950 you know those parallels but
you know very material differences
however I think that you know most of
the experiments have failed most efforts
to do something that's kind of
substantially different to the kind of
best practice of the day most of those
efforts fail and so I think when you're
designing a particular organization
doing something that like truly you
might kill it is just like a pretty
risky thing to do and evidently the way
Google Facebook Microsoft and others are
organized Amazon what have you you know
I'm certain it's not perfect I'm certain
that not only can you do better but you
can do substantially better I really
believe that but at the same time it's
kind of empirically adequate to be
Google Facebook you know Apple or Amazon
and I think doing better is is is just
really pretty difficult and so I
actually love the fact that people are
experimenting here
the rise of remote organizations that
you know have no physical headquarters
or you know attempts to have I mean
buffer has been trying sort of you know
this kind of radical transparency down
to connect compensation if some
organizations like medium and Zappos
tried or are trying Halak recei and so I
love the fact that all these experiments
are happening and can you define
holacracy for a second well I don't
deeply understand it but I I think it is
I think I believe as I understand it the
core idea is
is having kind of differing kind of
decision-making bodies like groups of
people that are responsible for major
areas of the company rather than having
a kind of more traditional hierarchy and
so perhaps again this is my superficial
understanding but so perhaps you might
have you know some set of people who are
responsible for making compensation
decisions some other set of people who
are responsible for deciding you know
what the product strategy should be for
next year and some other set of people
who are responsible for figuring out how
you know how the office should be
decorated but they're kind of those sets
of people don't need to kind of map on
to you know some traditional hierarchy
and making out of they can be partly
overlapping or you know bigger or
smaller or whatever and you know that's
a you know point wouldn't describes that
I don't think that's you know a priori a
ludicrous idea you know maybe that's a
work but I think kind of the the the
sort of the bias should be that for any
radical departure from the kind of
prevailing status quo it's probably not
going to work I think you know this is
probably a 90% chance maybe maybe higher
that kind of any any meaningful
deviation is a bad idea
and so again to kind of return to the
process of getting out at the beginning
I think we should celebrate the fact
that all these experiments are happening
and should really cheer them on and
should really hope that they succeed and
kind of we ourselves should choose maybe
some small number of experiments we
really believe in to it you know to
engage in but I think for these kind of
you know really high important or high
importance really hard to change sort of
trap door decisions like what kind of
organizational structure you know you're
gonna have I think you actually want to
bias towards being relatively
conservative yeah you don't you you
might be supportive of monkeys being
shot into space but you don't
necessarily want to be one of the first
ten right but I really think like one of
the strangest things to me in the world
you know as I look at is that people can
have to uncelebrated this
experimentation enough sort of like if
it doesn't seem to them like the right
thing to do
they are kind of offended by it or it's
you know
seems to there's some kind of emotional
response which whereas I think at least
the response I try to kind of cultivate
myself is I think that's a bad idea it
does not make sense given my model of
the world and I'm delighted it's
happening like that's so great
and if it fails well you know that's
unfortunate and if it succeeds you know
we all get to learn something that's
kind of that's what's so great about the
transmission of knowledge that if it
works at only one particular small
instance everyone gets to benefit from
it that's so cool and yet when people
try kind of you know strange things that
don't kind of match our kind of again
pre-existing comprehension you know
there's some combination of mockery or
or dismissiveness or again kind of
emotional objection at words I really
think we should be encouraging and
celebrating them and you know the
weirder the effort is that the more they
deserve our support so I want to talk
about what maybe some of the things you
did differently but not not only what
you did differently because that's sort
of a in some respects a causal factor
but in some respects a a downstream
effect of thinking differently or seeing
things differently so what did you guys
know that other people didn't because
I've heard multiple people comment on
the early conception of Stryper
considering entering a crowded market
with ton of existing incumbents with
regulatory and institutional barriers to
entry all of these types of factors why
did you decide to pursue that what did
you see that other people did not see in
that case um well I think there's two
different kinds of knowing right this
kind of conscious explicit knowing where
you know you see that there's kind of a
prevailing belief or something and you
understand why it's wrong and you have
some kind of proprietary insight that
everyone else doesn't have I think
there's another kind of sort of
quote-unquote knowing which is just you
you have a belief or a model of the
world and you don't even
realize that it's different to others
that you it's just it's kind of some
deeply internalized thing that just for
whatever circumstantial reasons you you
happen to have ended up with and I think
for us it actually wasn't so much that
we had a in the beginning this kind of
comprehensive deep understanding of the
space and realized how everyone else was
mistaken we just had like a particular
perspective you know because of how we
where we came from and how we got
started that and we were lucky we turned
out the kind of that model we had and
that outlook kind of matched the world
at that time but I really I think it's
very important that you know we don't
kind of drink our own kool-aid here and
and over-read into our sort of supposed
insight I really think you know it was
it was it was really just a lot of
circumstance and good fortune but I
would say that kind of particular things
that differed about stripe and kind of
our our outlook where we just didn't
think that the kind of regulatory and
kind of partnership / banking barriers
were actually that bad you know that
they kind of sound intimidating and
obviously you've to kind of do a lot of
work there that maybe a lot of other
software companies don't have to do but
you know it's it's it's fundamentally
feasible I mean ultimately regulators
and banks and so on are comprised of
good people who want to do the right
thing and may speak a different language
or whatever but are you know they're
they're reasonable and I guess the other
thing is we really had this mindset
because of because where we we came from
that the kind of developers and makers
and software we're just going to
continue to become increasingly
important and it's really amazing work
and when we started out we kind of our
idea was that developers were just like
we build a good product and developers
would start using it and you know that
that would be the story and we didn't
even know that was such a kind of a
stupid distribution strategy and go-to
market mechanism we didn't even know how
much Enterprise marketing and enterprise
sales motion and all the rest we were
kind of skipping over
we just can't have this very naive
understanding of the world however uh we
were lucky where the world really I
think started to change around 2010-2011
where companies around the world and
especially in kind the US and Europe
really got the memo like big traditional
companies that they would have to take
advantage of what software was making
possible and really transform themselves
if they wanted to kind of survive and
and prosper and so you know fast forward
kind of five or six years later even the
kind of more traditional kind of stodgy
or companies that would have needed this
kind of super complex enterprise field
team to kind of engage with they were
actually now starting to listen to their
own developers and when the CTO said hey
I really think we should be using this
kind of much more straightforward or
sort of much more powerful technology
unlike a decade before they were
actually being listened to and so again
this isn't sort of a thing we knew and
in the way that we could have you know
argued for us in in 2010 but it was a
thing we kind of was somehow in our
bones and again we were just lucky where
we started right around when the world
started to transform in this regard and
actually we did this we did this survey
earlier this year where we kind of
surveyed a whole bunch of you know I
don't to say can't traditional but but
sort of not software companies we sort
of surveyed companies you know fairly
broadly across multiple industries and
we just asked them kind of what what's
holding them back and you know that's a
very imperfect methodology of course
because you know it's it's hard to know
what the kind of candidate answers there
should be and maybe you know those
questions are do they all interpret it
the same way and so on but the kind of
very high level thing that sort of came
back was that companies across the board
report kind of availability of software
engineers and just like ability to kind
of do things with software as being as
big or even bigger a constraint on their
progress as access to capital
and that's just such an amazing fact
right in that sort of you know economics
for for for its history basically has
been sort of a science of in some sense
you know access to and kind of a
distribution of capital and we just had
this kind of moment of transformation
where I mean on some level you can
exchange you know capital for software
talent and and output and so on but it's
actually really hard to do and I think
companies will be really struggling with
figuring out how to make that happen and
so anyway we just had the good fortune
of getting started right when that came
to be the case so that there there are
definitely shouldn't say synchronicities
but sort of fortuitous timing aspects to
it and and I think that of course lady
lady fortune good luck or bad luck is
always a factor but it's it's in a case
like this necessary and not sufficient
right there are certain things within
your control assuming we don't get into
a really long confusing discussion about
free will let's just assume there are
certain things that depend on you making
very specific decisions there are these
these Forks in the road and I'd love to
talk about some of the things that you
feel like you did right or small things
that turn into big things and I'll read
I want to read just a very brief
paragraph from the Yoda mentioned
earlier Paul Graham and people are
interested in learning more about Y
Combinator we can talk about it but it's
and this is gonna be vastly simplified
but for people who have never heard this
before Y Combinator often abbreviate to
YC is the SEAL Team six Harvard of and
let's just call it startup incubators of
sorts they accept a class it is a very
small percentage I want to say single
digits at this point it would have to be
in terms of the number of applicants and
there are many many well-known companies
that have come out of of Y Combinator
and Paul has many fantastic essays
online which people should read YC is
one of the most amazing inventions of
the past 20 years
and I think PJ's essays are still a gold
mine that sort of like Alan Kay I think
are still like people kind of know
they're great but I think they're even
better than people appreciate though for
sure and a lot and many of them I've
also read his book many of them are they
are not timely in the best possible
sense they are they're they're based on
first principles and an example of that
I mean I always mess up the headline but
I think it's the makers schedule versus
the managers schedule something along
those lines people can find out I'll put
in the show notes but this particular
essay talks a bit about stripe and it's
a strike quote stripe is one of the most
successful startups we funded and the
problem they solved was an urgent one if
anyone would have sat back and waited
for users or could have sat back and
waited for users it was stripe but in
fact they're famous within YC for
aggressive early user acquisition
startups building things for other
startups have a big pool of potential
users and the in the other companies
we've funded and none took better
advantage of it than stripe and YC we
use the term quote Collison installation
and quote for the technique they
invented more definate founders ask will
you try our beta and for people who
don't know that terminology just means
effectively a rough draft of a product
will you try our beta and if the answer
is yes they say great we'll send you a
link but the call us and brothers
weren't going to wait when anyone agreed
to try stripe they'd say right then give
me your laptop and set them up on the
spot all right so that seems like a
small thing but it doesn't strike me
that if that's the beginning of certain
types of snowballs and user acquisition
that is a really important could be a
really important differentiator this is
so what are some of your free to take
this in any direction but some of the
the other thing is that that you guys
got right and I I do remember even in
Silicon Valley which of course is a can
be an echo chamber of sorts but there
was a lot of talk even at the periphery
of my circles and I am non-technical I'm
not a developer about how easy stripe
was to
implement right seven lines of code or X
number of lines of code and you're set
up and I'm sure that I'm sure on some
level was a very conscious decision not
only in terms of product but also in
terms of positioning so Kiki you talk
about some of the early decisions that
yeah in retrospect were really important
so I think there are two that really
jump out to me where you know I think
they were actually kind of somewhat
deliberate well what I'll give to and we
all think of more and so one is you know
we had sort of grown up reading slash
dot and this early kind of tech news
website but was kind of crowd sourced
and hacker news and Twitter and blogs
and you know all these kinds of services
and I guess we just sort of had a belief
that I hope you'll found out about
things in the world had changed and in
particular the kind of market was
getting more efficient and by efficient
I mean that it was becoming more likely
that people would come to discover the
kind of quote-unquote correct thing and
that maybe kind of thirty years ago or
something because they were sort of much
slower or fewer kind of distribution
channels that who won and what cut use
we kind of determined more by marketing
budgets or by sales tax or whatever but
that there was a new kind of sort of
transparency and kind of efficacy and
information dissemination that the
internet had possible that shifted the
way that sort of product could really
get adopted
and so just very concretely our sales
and marketing strategy for a very long
time was was writing blog posts that we
just thought were you know good and
interesting or just we hoped were and
building a good product and hoping that
people would tell others about it
and I really don't think that that would
have worked ten years previously it was
kind of the internet had changed but we
just kind of made a very deliberate bet
on makind of superior distribution
channels and I think that actually
really helped us in two big ways one is
it's kind of eeeh Slee cheaper and so
you look at a lot of other companies
especially companies selling to
businesses and they spend vast
gargantuan amount of money on their kind
of sales and marketing strategies and
severely on we just we didn't have to do
that and so you know it was kind of
transformative ly impactful in that
sense maybe if we'd had to kind of you
know spend a lot on sort of getting
started it perhaps would have been you
know that that could have been a severe
enough barrier that we wouldn't have
gotten over it at all maybe the company
would never have happened
so that's the first the second it I
paused for one second yeah sure
do you recall any of the blog posts that
if you were to do kind of an 80/20
analysis and look at those that really
move the needle do you recall any of the
topics or just your basic approach well
I remember and a guy who worked at
stripe and who still works at stripe his
name is Evan
he wrote a blog post about how to debug
Python which is a programming language
with gdb which is a debugger it didn't
really have much to do with stripe this
actually was a really good blog post and
this is probably back in 2012
and it's very like that got a whole
bunch of traffic and it you know as a
consequence people kind of found out
about stripe and maybe he kind of
realized that we use something of what
we were talking about from a technical
standpoint and and it moved the needle
for us and back at a time where really
nobody had heard of us it's it's also if
if I'm a I'm caffeinated enough now to
feel the need to jump in and and
commentate but the it's also a really
good example of an editorial honeypot
that will attract the types of people
who are technically probably in
positions to given that sort of point in
time that you discussed earlier where
CEOs are listening more to see CTOs and
CTOs are listening to the actual on the
front line
that's coders it was it's it very
our way of talking around the product in
a sense that a lot of those technical
folks in my experience are also semi
allergic or very highly allergic to what
they perceive as anything salesy so
you're able to bring them into the fold
without directly explicitly selling
anything yes well this actually brings
me to count the second thing that I was
going to mention in terms of the other
kind of helpful consequence of kind of
marketing ourselves this way which is it
actually kind of created better
incentives for us because if you think
that sort of more traditional marketing
and by way to be tear I'm not dismissing
in any way kind of traditional sales and
marketing I mean stripe has sales people
and marketing people and you know they
they're immensely important in sort of
in the organization we're not building
today and so I don't kind of
specifically talk about kind of
strategies to kind of get started in the
early days and to kind of get some
initial traction anyway that's it and
the super valuable thing about sort of
pursuing these kind of non-traditional
channels is if you think that a
traditional marketing organization I'm
kind of what it's or additional
marketing in general and kind of what
the incentives are the incentives are
kind of talk up the product or to kind
of pre announce things ahead of when
they're actually ready because if you're
sort of talking at people and you know
showing them these fancy presentations
or whatever but they're not actually
using the product directly you know if
they find out it sort of a year later
that it sucks well you know that that's
kind of fine or at least it's fine in
the short term because you know you've
already got the revenue for the sale or
something
whereas if you have to compete on the
merits of the product and just going to
rely on people kind of being honest
about how well it works or doesn't that
kind of forces you to just build a kind
of product development organization that
can compete and so it might be harder to
kind of get that initial traction but if
you can get there you actually really
have kind of an upper hand relative to
kind of more traditionally incentivize
companies because they've probably
gotten a bit lazy and a bit will suffice
and just a bit less competitive on this
axis and once you can make the battle
about the quality of your product and
the quality of your product development
you know if you if you can get the the
battle fields to be sort of on that axis
you really have a huge advantage
and our experience was the incumbents
just couldn't react and you know they
kind of realized that stripe was kind of
getting some traction and starting to
get some mindshare and developers and
startups were starting to use it and
what's really amazing to me is kind of
how little happened and I think it's not
because I mean obviously for a while
it's going to dismiss to us but even
after they stopped dismissing us it you
know you you can't just kind of click
your fingers we're like okay now we're
going to start creating good products
it's such a deep cultural and
organizational thing that it's it's very
difficult for competitors or potential
competitors to shift there whereas if
you just have a better marketing
campaign that's super easy to copy and
anyone else can you buy a competing
billboard or pay more for the Google
heads or whatever and so I'm again we
didn't kind of realize all this in
advance but I think that ended up really
helping us yeah I want to underscore
something you just mentioned briefly
which is Google Ads
right this is what two things number one
is that if I look back at the however
many at this point seventy plus startups
in my own investment experience the vast
majority of over performers focused
almost to the exclusion of PR and
marketing on product in the early days
and number two is if I look at the
bottom performing say decile of
companies they almost all got very
distracted by PR and marketing
particularly in the first year or two
generally first year of existence
especially if they were blessed
in other words cursed with a lot of high
praise from outlets and one or two
pieces it's very seductive as a cyber my
song absolutely and the the the last
thing I wanted to say just to underscore
something you mentioned which is really
important is if your customer
acquisition is predicated on paid
acquisition yes
that makes you a just a sitting duck for
incumbents exact
who have larger budgets yes and they can
just decide to bleed chips for a period
of time until you run out of chips yes
this is a yeah it's really really
important so I'm glad you mentioned it
there's all other kind of a seductive
psychological temptation where if
something isn't growing to tell yourself
that it's because well you know I
haven't invested enough in distribution
it's kind of harder to sort of come to
realize or to tell yourself that well
you know maybe our baby is just bit too
ugly and so I think kind people are just
very psychologically biased towards sort
of blaming and anything about growth on
things that sound like sales and
marketing and then the yeah I mean kind
of related to what you just said one of
they're just really strange facts about
the world and I don't kind of fully
understand why this is the case is how
hard it is for organizations to build
good software and you know I know that
sounds strange in that I mean lots of
organizations build some software but
like it is just really weird right you
know if you if you think about sort of
what a what a really good website or iOS
application or whatever kind of is and
feels like and it's really strange I
mean it's not easy to build a really
good website or iOS app or whatever but
it's not rocket science I'm given that
it's not rocket science
why are there so few of them like just
think of kind of any big major company
and think of their website or app like
it's probably pretty bad it kind of
janky it looks old
like the animations already work right
it's kind of it's laggy all that stuff
right but that's weird they probably
have the pride of a nice building and
ice headquarters and you know if they
like there are many things they can
decide to do and and just like do it
pretty competently they can kind of turn
their capital advantage into a into a
sort of an advantage in some other area
like if they
I don't know if they want to if they
want to have a great fleet of cars you
know they can very reliably turn capital
into a great fleet of cars but for some
reason they can't seem to turn and in
fact they can probably even turn capital
into like a cool advertising campaign
you know there's enough good agencies
but for whatever reason they can't turn
capital into good software and you know
it would be immensely valuable for them
if they could but they can't or at least
they don't and I don't think it's for
lack of trying or lack of kind of
realizing this and so I think actually
smaller companies don't realize how much
of an upper hand they have here where if
they can create a product that is kind
of so much better than the status quo
that they start to get sort of organic
traction once you attach a real sales
and marketing engine to that it's going
really freaking hard
for a big company to effectively compete
because again this kind of
organizational transformation into being
good at software is just is just so
profoundly hard another place that I've
seen a lot of would-be entrepreneurs or
entrepreneurs spend a lot of time on
company name and brand okay so it was
choking with I was joking with Chris
Sacca earlier via text and I was just
saying I'm really impressed with the
phenomenal outcomes and very rocky
beginnings with like difficult names
that you guys have had with companies
guys so you have octo Matic which which
I'm sure was not always spelled
correctly by people not not uniformity
now and stri stripe what could you just
give us a a brief description of the
original name of what would later become
stripe and just like walk us through
some early iterations because I want
everyone what I'm hoping to do here and
I don't want to make this too leading of
an introduction to what you're going to
say but is that you're like the
future of your company is probably not
going to hinge entirely on the first
name that you give it is where I'm
trying to go with this and the product
that maybe you could just tell a bit of
the story we are definitely a powerful
example of that that as you say it is
not
and so stripe was originally
incorporated as slash dev slash Finance
Inc spelled SL a sh devs la SH etcetera
like the it was slashes or she spelled
out and and the reason for that is you
know we well it's a long story I won't
bore you with it it was like a
programming joke but you know we thought
it was funny and I think it was the rest
of the world you know to our shock and
surprise did not quite find it as funny
as we did and and the the the first name
of the product was /type /page because
you know we we should have wanted a
slightly broader company name than
product name and I'm extremely
confusingly while the company had all
this SLA SH stuff spelled out the
product was just de Vie payments calm
and so kind of the naming schemas didn't
even really match and so we would have
these meetings and we described we do
and we're already fighting an uphill
battle here I mean you know we were as
John says sort of you know three
squirrels in a trench coat sort of trend
of masquerade as like a real thing and
like evading all these questions about
you know where exactly their
headquarters and you know how do we say
how do we not say our bedroom in a way
that's not a lie and or how do we say we
have an open floor plan exactly exactly
yes yeah we really embrace remote work
um so we were already finding a bit of
an uphill battle and you know then at
the end of the meeting or something you
know they'd ask us our name or for a
business card or something we'd have to
hand over this thing that you know
doesn't even look like a company name
they'd look at it as like oh but you
know what's the company name called like
actually sorry sir it's this thing so it
was just it was all bad and not only did
people often misspelled --is-- but it
was kind of a moment of celebration if
anyone ever correctly spelled it
and so we kind of came to accept the
need for for a name change and naming
things as I'm sure you know is pretty
hard and so I remember I think was the
winter of 2010 which was a very wet
winter out in California unusually and I
just remember all these kind of dark
evenings at the office for as soon as
you just kind of got stuck with your
coat or with some problem or something
you we would have some a little
discussion about well what could we name
this company and we had all these books
around the office I mean just all sort
of random stuff you just page through
them and like come up with a word and
and you know toss it out to the group we
were like well should we call our
company this and so Umbra John was
trying to learn how to ride a motorcycle
and so we had a motorcycle repair manual
and so a lot of motorcycle words should
be called a company carburetor which
fortunately did not make the cut
and so it was not going well as you're
hearing we eventually decide to write a
little script so just like kind of
random potential names and actually to
kind of check whether the relevant
domain names were available because you
know it was important for an online
company that we can I have the coms
domain and I can t remember how but
stripe is one of the words that ended up
sort of on our list of names to check I
think we're just at some point trying to
think up kind of single monosyllabic
English words that didn't have some kind
of strong pre-existing Association and
stripe it turns out was available you
know relatively cheaply it was you know
who was I think 10 or 20 thousand
dollars which you know that's not cheap
in some sense but compared to the costs
we were living I'm having a terrible
name it seems like a good deal that's
the way what year was this this is like
2010 so that's astonishing to me that's
actually I mean for a dictionary word
that is a noun that recognizable that's
astonishing did you Nick did you
negotiate or have someone negotiate on
your behalf or was that the opening
offer they made to sell I'd have to go
back to check the details but but
there wasn't a big lengthy negotiation
and the yeah this back and forth you
know we really lucked out I mean what
helped us of course is we weren't wedded
to any of these names right you know if
if the guy had said you know it's two
hundred thousand dollars well you know
that would have been exactly two seconds
of thought we'd have moved on to
something else under carburetor code
exactly exactly as it really helped that
you know we were happy to entertain
anything at all and and the last thing
worth mentioning there is you know we
okay we bought the domain and started
you know rename all our code and the
website and everything and then one day
in early January we kind of flip the
switch and everything became stripe and
we'd somehow have a checklist of all the
things to change and do we Dan it
elected to add an entry for tell our
customers and so you know people woke up
in the morning to go to death payments
like come and check their sales and
whatever and you know they get
redirected to stripe comm and so we got
a lot of confused customers being like
are you guys hacked have you been fished
and what's going on here
fortunately back in January 2011 we had
very few customers and so when I say we
got these emails from customers I mean
probably all five of our customers
emailed us so it was not a huge customer
support burden what I do want to talk
about may perhaps some inflection points
for the company since you you certainly
have more than five customers now I mean
you have what is it eighty percent of
American adults have purchased something
from a business powered by stripe now I
know that doesn't mean that there are
eighty percent of American adults are
stripe customers per se yeah but that's
right you now have millions of
businesses in 130 plus countries so
something happened between those two
points in time yes but so it'd be easy
to talk about a lot of the highlights a
lot of the inflection points and we will
do that but lest this appear like it has
been home run after home run every time
you've stepped up to bat but I'd love to
talk about if you're willing are some of
the harder periods maybe near-death
experiences moments of doubt and to make
it as personal as possible right so not
necessarily in abstract about the
company going through a tough time but
periods when
you have struggled and to give us one or
two examples of that and then how you
kind of found your way out of that
period would be I think certainly of
interest to me and hopefully would help
humanize the otherwise seemingly
superhuman Patrik Karlson this could
also be a personal period could be could
have been high school college a
difficult family situation could be
anything I will I'll give him the stripe
version the first version um so it's
okay with those caveats on the UH the
stripe side just the the thing that I
think is kind of important to
communicate is despite things having
been relatively smooth in that macro
sense it often is just extremely hard
and I remember sort of early on after
I'm after one particular meeting back in
I don't know 2011 2012 like just after
the meeting the API broke and so you
know those are the API application
programming interface could you just
yeah the core stripe payments engine
broke and so our customers just couldn't
get paid and couldn't accept payments
from their customers and you know we
didn't have many customers back then
maybe there were a hundred or something
but but yeah there was still a hundred
businesses it felt like a huge deal and
you know we fixed it it was only down
for me 30 minutes or something but I'm
ever feeling it really bad about that
and then I just remember kind of it
wasn't like there was something kind of
particularly special about that day but
I remember just kind of I guess
reflecting on the sort of enormity of
the challenges that you know we would
face in the future and all the work we
still have to do and all the stuff that
was still broken and all the people we
had to hire and all the customers we'd
have to convince to use us that you know
we had not yet convinced and it was just
kind this moment of vertigo and I mean I
just remember being kind of immensely
dispirited and kind of talking to John
about well you know is there really
action
any point doing this and again what's
kind of important to me about that
moment is not that kind of things were
actually all that bad but but kind of
the opposite objectively they were fine
that date wasn't really much worse than
the previous day but I think the kind of
there's this kind of inevitable thing
when you're creating something where on
the one hand you have to be kind of very
optimistic because if you weren't
optimistic you wouldn't bother doing it
especially in the face of such hardship
and uncertainty you also have to be very
pessimistic because you have to I mean
there are tons of problems and you have
to be kind of very um kind of tuned to
spotting them so you can go fix them and
so you kind of exist in this kind of
superposition this juxtaposition of kind
of pessimism and optimism and you're
kind of an extreme and both axes and
that's just like a weird psychological
state and to remain in it as you must
for kind of many years is it's just not
normal and you're kind of you're always
sort of necessarily over extrapolating
from limited data because again you kind
of should be in that like you know one
particular customer decides not to use
you or one particular person leaves the
company or you know just like some small
thing happens but you kind of have to be
really asking yourself well is this a
trend is there has something changed is
something systemically broken whatever
and because you're kind of always
extrapolating from from these bad things
while maintaining this kind of long term
optimism um I think that is just a
recipe for for real you know
[Music]
psychological you know hardship and you
know I want to overstate it and that you
know the kind of is all the obvious sort
of them
I don't know acknowledgments about you
know were immensely lucky among the
luckiest people in history to have you
know food and shelter and health and all
these things but you know humans hedonic
Lee does the the hedonic treadmill is
very powerful and we rapidly adapt to
kind of take all those for granted and
so the fact that maybe in the scheme of
things we should feel very grateful and
lucky and you can kind of tell yourself
this narrative to try to keep things in
perspective the reality is that it is
just kind of pretty pummeling
on an ongoing basis even for stripe
which perhaps from the outside might
look like this kind of really neat
little story and their different kind of
many such moments for it just seems hard
that that what did the conversation look
like with John that day do you recall
any of the specifics I mean was it was
it more commiseration so you could get
out of your system were you actually
talking to him to determine if I should
proceed or not what was what what did
that look like it was more that the
former liked more this just instead of
general dejection we didn't seriously
think about stopping I think both of us
are it's less I think we're both really
determined and more I think we're just
stubborn and and so the idea of stopping
just it didn't seem like a just I guess
I didn't feel like an option for us I
know did determination sounds glamorous
to me and I'm not sure we have that but
I think we're just dogged but but yeah
it's more like you know people have
different kind of emotional sort of
cycles and kind of his sine-wave was
kind of displaced from mine and so
fortunately and you know he's a pretty
cheery guy that day when I was super
dejected he was a you know in his a
chipper way he was he was telling me
that would be fine
and you know you give it another 24
hours or something and you know the
world looks a bit different this is
something you mentioned just a few
moments ago I think is worth trying to
reiterate to make sure I understand it
which is the importance I mean the
existential importance in the case of a
lot of startups of being able to remain
consistently optimistic enough that you
can summon the energy and doggedness to
continue while also being very good at
envisioning problems and worst-case
scenarios and bad outcomes that you can
avert them and and yes it's tricky it's
really tricky lutely
it's true also for a half yeah go ahead
well I and it's it's for you know it's
not natural
and it's it's not a kind of mindset that
I think most normal situations in the
world kind of train you'd have yeah and
it can be really really stressful this
is something I've observed not only in
founders but also in a lot of investors
particularly those who can make money by
betting on in some fashion apocalyptic
or a Black Swan events that cause a lot
of damage or that are very scary and
people who are not just betting on the
long side but betting on the short side
and I mean of course we get into
derivatives and stuff like that but it's
it's the they're thinking about the edge
cases that could really be yes
catastrophic for for them and others
right uh although when you're selling a
company you sort of have to be kind of
both the sort of super long optimistic
you know I'm just gonna buy this stock
and hold it for decades trader and you
can I have to be this sort of the the
catastrophic yeah Taleb style you know
the world is going to hell in a
handbasket the sort of catastrophe
trader and you're you kind of has to be
both and that's just weird
and I guess the thing that I think this
may be important to understand for folks
is it's kind of intuitive that if a
company or a new effort of any sort is
not going well the things will feel hard
and you'll often feel dejected and life
at least insofar as work goes is not
great but the weird part is that even if
things are going well and the effort or
the company or whatever is succeeding
things will still often not feel great
and no one's told me that before I
started I I sort of thought that well if
the company is succeeding then clearly
it's going to be an unnecessarily fun
but at least sort of it'll feel good
day-to-day where is the actual reality
is that you're always necessarily
operating at the kind of outer edge of
what you can handle because you know if
it was if you'd spare capacity you just
take out more and so you're kind of
therefore inevitably always you know on
the cusp of feeling it you're you're
sort of
to fall over and you know even as we
record this podcast I mean I thought
this kind of moment III feel sort of
right on the edge of what I'm what I'm
able to handle and on the one hand I
sort of I don't wish it were otherwise
and that I sort of enjoy testing myself
and kind of finding my limits and and
developing and stretching myself but on
the other hand you know when you stretch
your muscles that's painful well it also
makes me think of a conversation I had
with Laird Hamilton his one of the most
legendary big-wave surfers of all time
and I remember a scatting with him he's
got to be I don't know how old he is
he's one of those guys who sort of
defies any type of expectation of age
affecting performance I think he's in
his early 50s but still goes hunting for
some of the biggest waves in the world
and I remember I was chatting with him
at one point and he said he'd been
tooling around on some easy waves
earlier that day and I asked him roughly
how big he thought they were and he was
like you know 20 25 feet he's like once
you get to 20 you can start to have fun
and I'm paraphrasing here buddy's like
once you get to 30s like you really want
kind of want to watch yourself it's like
once you get to over 50 you're really
not allowed to fall and it's when you
are and I've never been in this position
but having spent a lot of time around
founders and very fast growing companies
when you do have at least the perception
and which i think is reflective of
reality that you are effectively always
on the edge of red lining because as you
said if you have extra capacity you open
the door to fill that capacity who are
some of the people you've leaned on or
who have been helpful alive or dead or
otherwise I'm not sure what otherwise
would be in that case but zombie to help
you navigate this or learn how to surf
that kind of wave because it is it is
[ __ ] unimaginable for most people
I've only seen it as a spectator really
what it takes to to kind of have your
face pressed up against the windshield
right in there in the Formula One car
that is a stripe or a new
or any of these companies it's it's
really hard to fathom what it what it
takes and how much it resembles a
professional sport right so who or what
has been helpful in learning to navigate
that well made just before answering
that to kind of add something to we were
just talking about though it relates to
what you just asked there's a period and
in my life where I you know I did feel a
bit naívi last but you know it it
certainly wasn't clear exactly what
direction I was going in and so we sold
our first company and I lived in
Vancouver for a while
worked for that company I got kind of
exploring some other stuff as well
this is live good idea exactly yep and
then I moved to live with my then
girlfriend in Zurich I mean so I lived
in Switzerland for a while and then and
then I actually went back to college
because I dropped out of college pretty
early and when I went to school I should
have thought well maybe I want to become
like a physicist or a mathematician or
something like that and you know who
knows how successful if at all I would
have been maybe maybe I wouldn't even
made the cut but you know I kind of had
that ambition aspiration and I sort of
felt that we'd started the company so
early and it happened so quickly that I
hadn't kind of really fully tested
whether that was kind of a good idea or
not and so I went back to college for a
second time and to kind of do mostly
math and physics and so did that and
then while there John was also in
college at the same time that's kind of
when we you know when to start stripe
but if you'd look to that kind of
two-year period it was drop out of
college start this company moved to
Vancouver moved to this other country go
back to college then start this other
company and like when we started stripe
it did not seem very promising I mean
seemed like this you know silly little
developer payment's thing and again well
it was another two years before it even
launched and so maybe that whole kind of
four year period I think to many people
who knew me or just kind of were around
like it I'm
it looks kind of pretty scattered kind
of weirdly planned may misdirected and
and you know they wouldn't be entirely
wrong I mean I certainly was not kind of
pursuing some some grand master plan and
I think I was actually really lucky
where you know from from sort of an
early age my parents were very okay with
myself and John sort of charting our own
course and you know you get these kind
of real sort of hot habits environments
for there's a lot of pressure to you
know go to the school go to this college
you know pursue this Krueger path
whatever you you really kind of feel
like you're on these kind of narrow
train tracks and I'd say that our
upbringing was kind of the opposite
where really our parents even when we
wanted to make sort of very ostensibly
kind of strange and surprising decisions
our parents kind of supported us and so
when I was a 15 year old and wanted to
take a year off school to kind of just
like program full-time my parents were
supportive of that or when I wanted a
sort of sort of drop out of school to go
take this you know totally different
exam system
my parents were okay with that and so I
you know we kind of had this upbringing
where our parents supported us in that
way and when in my kind of know teens
early 20s it was kind of trying to
figure out what the kind of right
direction was the I wouldn't say that
was kind of a lost period but it was
again it was definitely a highly
exploratory one and and so just come to
your question of you know periods of
real hardship I think a lot of people
either don't get the opportunity to sort
of explore multiple directions like that
or they're kind of either others don't
given the opportunity or they sort of
they don't kind of give themselves the
permission to just kind of have a few
you know slightly last year's where the
narrative isn't super clear and those
weeds can be hard because kind of by
definition you're not exactly sure where
they're going and it's very kind of
disorienting to not know where you're
sailing and and and you can and do feel
a bit of drift and so looking back on
that I actually feel like it was kind of
really important and kind of giving me
confidence in perspective but
the time it definitely felt a bit on
board well I think that you I think this
is really important for a number of
reasons the first is that and this is
going to sound like a fortune cookie but
there there is a quote I can't I can't
recall who it's attributed to I want to
say Emerson but Emerson is kind of like
Abraham Lincoln on the internet it's
like everything gets a true hero Oscar
Wilde that's right right so not not all
not all who wander are lost right so
there's a difference between being lost
which is you have a destination and you
have gone off track or you were
preoccupied with where you are currently
located and don't know where you're
located versus exploring and wandering
that's the second which is I suppose
more a follow-up question than a point
is is this I'm very curious how your
parents and maybe you can also just tell
us a little bit about what your parents
did professionally or how they spent
their time but how your parent what your
parents did to cultivate excellence or
clear end or clear thinking without
necessarily pigeonholing the direction
of those right is so if you if if a
biographer at some point is writing the
story of your life you give them
unfettered access how about they they
answer that you know what are the what
what are examples they might give things
your parents said annual routines that
you guys had or whatever anything that
comes to mind well I'm we were kind of
we grew up in very rural Ireland right
the kind of the middle of the
countryside surrounded by kind of farms
and fields and you know we were kind of
really we had to kind of figure out
ourselves I was going to be under
painting and interesting and fun it
wasn't just going to provided I'm you
know to us by the environment and so we
kind of grew up as these sort of
free-range children and they were lucky
where there were lots of books in the
house and we you know read those pretty
voraciously you know our parents I guess
I'd say that the thing that our parents
did is
there's a million things but the kind of
the two that really the three that stand
out are they kind of showed us the world
they took us to the library every day
they sort of took us you know traveling
in the summers they if there were
interesting guests coming over for
dinner we weren't kind of you know
dispatched you know upstairs or totally
get an early dinner before the adults
came we were sort of thrust right into
the middle so they kind of really took
us seriously and showed us the world the
second thing is they they really give us
kind of agency on autonomy and kind of
treated us as adults and you know that
was kind of it went two ways and that on
the one hand they give us a lot of
freedom on the other hand they kind of
expected quite a lot of us and so our
youngest brother had to get some pretty
major surgery in the u.s. back when John
and I were I don't know maybe ten or
twelve or thereabouts and so they were
gone to the US for several weeks maybe
more than a month and we were left
mostly alone for for that month we did a
neighbor who checked in on us every day
and you know made sure things were fine
but we spent most of the time alone when
we were at school and you know that they
the firm from myself and John standpoint
that was fantastic you know we really we
loved the freedom and but of course they
reciprocally expected us you know not to
to kind of not to give them cause to
regret it and and then the third thing
is you know whenever we kind of
expressed interest in something they
they really sort of tried to find
opportunities to kind of you know when
there was a small shoot of interest they
look for opportunities to water it but
they never sort of thrust those
opportunities on us or I never felt that
kind of or rather they were thrust the
interest on us I never felt that I was
sort of following a track laid down by
somebody else and so I remember kind of
randomly mentioning when I was 12 or 13
that learning I don't remember why I
thought this but the learning ancient
Greek seemed interesting I
I think I just like read some Homer or
something I mean a translation and and
the none of the language seemed
interesting and I was just you know
saying that as some kind of a random
throwaway remark I guess the way a kid
does and sure enough my mom went and
found somebody at like literally a local
monastery who's willing to teach ancient
Greek and and then she told me about
this and so for two years I went to that
monastery once a week after school and
like learned ancient Greek and that
interest never went you know super far I
haven't read much ancient Greek in the
last ten years
me neither but you know it was the kind
of thing they did and you know obviously
some other interests like programming
you know they kind of really took hold
in a deeper way and so you know I don't
have kids today but III do kind of
reflect a lot on the kind of childhood
we had because you know it was pretty
different in multiple regards to sort of
the childhoods of the people around us
and like especially when I got to
college in the u.s. it was sort of so
far and for me the idea that like people
were so laden with extracurriculars and
sort of furnishing their college resumes
you know from age 12 or earlier and the
kind of the period of sort of new
teenager hood and adolescence was kind
of so intense for is for myself and John
it really felt kind of exploratory and
that we were given a that our parents
were kind of life coaches or like
facilitators while we were yeah exactly
while we were roaming but that kind of
all the yeah exactly I think that they
were playing a supporting role rather
than you know having us be kind of uh
you know with these friends in college
it felt like they were kind of at the
front of a locomotive and the locomotive
was speeding along down the tracks and
there was kind of hanging on for dear
life being you know pushed along by the
by the the cattle protector when when
you had these dinners the this is
something that is that has popped up a
few times in conversations with a number
of folks on the podcast that the parents
had them included in specifically dinner
discussions when interesting house
guests would come over that's
interesting I never yeah I think that's
coming out it's come up a few times not
dozens of times but enough where it
piqued my curiosity to dig into it a bit
would your parents encourage you to ask
questions with jury it was there and
actually just so people can paint a
picture in their own minds
what did both of your parents work one
of them what did they do professionally
or how did they spend their time just so
we have a little contest and so both of
them worked our dad most of our
childhood ran a small kind of Lakeside
Hotel and 24 bedrooms and so he was kind
of it was a few miles from our house and
he spent a lot of time there and of
course for us as kids I mean it was
super exciting I mean this hotel was
like this was this giant playground as
far as we were concerned you know the
staff didn't appreciate that but and we
loved roaming around us and going and
sliding around the you know polished
function room floor and all the rest and
our mom started at a corporate training
company back right around the time I was
born I think she she had left her
previous job and then I was born and you
know I think after a couple of weeks she
decided well I don't know this kid isn't
that interesting and so from the house
she decided to start this company that I
would kind of provide him corporate
quality management training and so if I
heard these acronyms like ISO 9000 these
kind of certification programs they
should have yeah yeah and so kind of
threw all these American multinationals
setting up shop in Ireland and there's
got a lot of appetite for sort of making
sure that we're kind of doing things
properly and well and so on and so she
saw this business again providing did
this training and so they see all
through my childhood she was running
this business well for much of it out of
her house and then they kind of got a
cut a separate office but but sort of it
was it was always part of the picture
and so kind of from our standpoint
starting a company was really not some
kind of strange foreign thing it was it
was it was pretty normal I think
whatever your parents do is kind of but
almost you know
from the child's perspective is just
kind of is normal and I'm sure if our
parents been astronauts you know being
an astronaut would just seem like a
totally normal career and so so that's
what they did
mm-hmm it didn't you mentioned travel
you could you was it could is there a
particular trip that comes to mind and
I'd be cured there are many different
ways to travel and they're just as there
are many different ways to live and
choose places to live and so on so we we
probably won't have time to get into how
your parents ended up where you grew up
if they were started there or ended up
there which is a whole separate side of
things but yes yeah could you describe
perhaps a particularly memorable trip
sure and how you traveled with your
parents like what what that looked like
um yeah so so we went almost every
summer camping in Europe and so we'd
take the ferry to Europe which you know
from Ireland obviously isn't that far
and and we bring you know some tents or
a little caravan and we just go kind of
driving around the continent staying at
all these different campgrounds and
Europe turns out - can I have all these
really great nice campgrounds almost
every town has one and so we'd stay a
few days here made a week there and so
on and you'll be France and Germany and
Austria and Hungary and Italy and
whatever and I have these kind of
incredibly fond memories of of those
trips and I mean they'd be like a a
month long and and they were great I
guess because they're kind of long
enough that you didn't feel kind of
pressed for time or like okay today we
got to go see you know this time and the
other you kind of shifted into just kind
of camping mode and and there were life
changes of scenery an environment did
you sort of just got to take a whole lot
of different things in I mean honestly
the other thing it was great about them
is even though you know being in Ireland
there wasn't kind of a whole lot of
distraction we also just kind of read a
lot or kind of focus on our own things
on these trips you you could focus and
read even more
and so honestly they may the most kind
of vivid memories I have mostly of these
trips it's not sort of going to see the
such-and-such or so and so it's like
particular books that I read and I mean
I remember you know we kind of load up
the the car and the caravan which is
like heaps and heaps of books and you
know you'd have these long drives like
you know eight hours ten hours I'm just
kind of reading in the car the whole way
ISM listening to your stories and more
about your childhood and and so on a lot
of which is is brand new to me
I'm simultaneously looking at a page on
your website Patrick Collison com
forward slash advice and this this may
not apply to everybody in my
listenership I think a lot of them do
apply to many different age ranges but
it starts with if you're if you're 10 to
20 these are prime here so a lot of
folks will fall outside of that but I
wanted to touch on a few of these sure
and one is alright so the the the these
two kind of go together but one is make
things and then there's a line following
it but then following up on that is more
broadly nobody is going to teach you to
think for yourself a large fraction of
what people around you believe is
mistaken internalized and practice
coming up with your own worldview you
have the correlation between it and
those around you shouldn't be too strong
unless you think you were especially
lucky in your initial conditions or this
is my language now you choose your
environment like a place like San
Francisco or whatever it might be but
the the and I suppose even then if the
correlation is too high you should be
careful Ooty
but the submission here is gonna be a
little meandering so bear with me but
okay there are people who seem to not
not care what other people think and
develop their own worldviews because
they have a predisposition in that
direction in the sense that you can have
a very good basketball player there are
certain skills you can work on to become
a better basketball
Claire but if they say you should try as
hard as possible to be tall it's going
to be difficult to change that attribute
there are a lot of people in Silicon
Valley who are somewhere on the spectrum
let's say and have may actually have
diagnoseable say Asperger's which in
some previous times could have been a
very maladaptive trade yes that would
have been a sort of selection criteria
for removal from the gene pool that is
now in this new context in fact in some
instances a competitive advantage
because they're sort of lack of
absorbing world views from others or
feeling that pressure enables them to
come up with their own perspective and
orientation so if we filter those people
out right because the they may be
similarly difficult to imitate in a
sense as a basketball player is to
imitate in their height how how are
there any books any documentaries and he
approaches or just any mental models or
maybe anything at all that people can
use to internalize thinking for
themselves to practice coming up with
their own worldview like what is what
are your thoughts well mmm this is kind
of the this is the big question right
and yeah maybe they're kind of two
halves probably heuristics you should
have and use we're gonna who and want to
listen to and then yeah secondly
separately how do you how do you think
for yourself and I think okay I'll sort
enumerate 'm particular heuristics or
tricks
i'm not sure this is a complete answer
but the first is when you see a smart
person holding a point of view and
especially strongly holding a point of
view there's kind of difference to your
own rather than trying to figure out how
they're wrong try to
I mean that's valuable but you'll
inevitably do that you're kind of you
know your emotional brain will ensure
you do trying to figure out Heather
right like what is a sensible worldview
in which what they believe or what
they're saying actually kind of does
make sense and that doesn't mean they're
right but sort of trying to figure out
like if they're not stupid why would
they believe this and so you know I am
I'm personally you know very in favor of
kind of openness to immigration I've
obviously benefited from it myself I
think there should be more of it in the
world but I think we can't just kind of
dismiss people who oppose immigration as
kind of you know nativists bigots I
think we're gonna have to ask the
questions and just try to understand
well what could or would cause somebody
to harbor concerns there right so that
that's one instead of trying to figure
out what worldview helps have a view
make sense a second one is and we kind
of touched on this at the beginning of
the conversation just exposing yourself
to more worldviews because I think a lot
of people well everyone finds it more
comfortable to be around kind of views
that accord with your own and models
that accord with your own and so there's
a kind of deliberate seeking out of
discomfort and you know I do some of
this myself in kind of who I follow on
Twitter and Reid and even though I spend
time with we're sort of trying to make
sure that like I expose myself to people
who have kind of smart thoughtful and
really like pretty different
perspectives on important matters can
you I have to pause because this just
seems too fertile to let go quickly are
there any people on Twitter you can give
as examples you just said they're smart
and thoughtful so you're they it's not
you know you're already complimented
yeah yeah you know we can also [ __ ] mark
and come back to it if it's hard to come
up with yeah I mean I've a we can think
of a few
I can come back but it's a good question
and maybe the other one is the kind of
general heuristic or habit here or
something is just to not get mad and to
not get offended in that you know
outrage and offense and anger are there
sometimes useful of course but I think
they're sort of useful they're less
useful than well they're over utilized
they're not useful as often as they are
invoked and and I think for whatever
reason the kind of the ability to not
take offense and to kind of sort of
inspect and to try to understand and to
even try to kind of really extrapolate
from an idea or a set of ideas or a
worldview
without taking offense at us that's not
something that for whatever reason is
kind of really valued in our culture but
I think is actually super important can
you as you know as has been said can you
run an idea in emulation in your head
like in in computers people talk about
you know running running VMs right I
mean ews you upload your software your
code they run it on their servers but
they run it in emulation and they kind
of in a little sandbox to make sure that
it can kind of break out and affect
other users applications and so kind of
similarly can you run an idea and
scrutinize it and inspect it and kind of
follow its consequences and you know
without it kind of bleeding out into
kind of the rest of your brain and sort
of infecting your whole world of you I
think the ability to do that without
kind of getting angry or taking offence
is really super powerful because if you
can do that you can then afford to kind
of anyway you can be less careful about
what ideas you you you inspect and
scrutinize and so you can just kind of
you can be much more sort of far
reaching and kind of broadly ranging and
then are there any people in your life
or who you're aware of you particularly
respect for being good at doing this
doing this meaning being non emotionally
reactive to using opposing viewpoints
and I and I should say also I'm looking
at your followers on Twitter which
people can find at Patrick's see that's
your account and I just want to give an
example of to contrast see if one harsh
sik sik ka yes bio applying biological
constraints to building intelligent
robust and generalizable systems at
Harvard at Georgia Tech at UC San Diego
right next to at reloj almighty almighty
fellow and bio is all mightier a load
the hustlers say hello to the bad guy
they say I'm a bad guy dot dot so those
are a lot of lot of professors a lot of
researchers also here's a friend of mine
you follow Graham Duncan really
interesting guy yeah I made a list of
some people I follow at Patrick Collison
dot-com slash people and I wouldn't say
that all of them are excellent at this
sort of sort of not taking offense and
it's sort of trying to find the best in
some particular idea we're trying to
find you know whatever truth is in it
but I would say as a general matter they
are mm-hmm and why is it when I look at
some of your posts I also a Twitter list
called reading which is basically the
same list but something easy easy to
follow a format and so you know anyone
can go follow that list and I think
actually a reason whatever people that
do and you you seem to whether it's
reading or people have an intense
interest in looking at your Patrick
austin.com forward slash people right
now yeah you do have some great John
Arnold it's definitely worth checking
out for a lot of folks who will not
recognize that name of course Stewart
Brand a lot lots of
lots of good people on this list so I
encourage people to check this out but
coming back to one name that popped up
when I was looking on your Twitter
account which I think you also recently
shared pseudo Erasmus through their
asthma so economic history and
development economics this feed contains
no current events no political news new
culture and no capital letters history
of economics the Hutt why do you seem so
interested in economics economic
progress in some cases economic history
certainly can seem very niche but I
suspect there's a lot more to to that
labor repression and the Indo Japanese
divergence is the pin tweet by Erasmus
yeah why read so much of this type of
stuff because it's so important in that
the arguably the single most important
thing kind of about our lives compared
to other lives have been lived in human
history is that we have the immense good
fortune to have being born in wealthy
societies and that has had so many
consequences in our lives right I mean
it means that our you know our parents
are way more likely to be alive our
siblings are far more likely to be alive
we get to work on things we find instead
of way more interesting than you know
tilling in the field or foraging for
bushes it means we're sort of exposed to
kind of the full you know a more
complete picture of the kind of variety
and complexity and fascination or
fascinating material of the world hey I
don't need to obviously enumerate all of
this but just like it's it's astounding
comparative of all humans who ever lived
just how amazingly lucky we are and
again that luck is is we were born into
a wealthy society and so I think kind of
one of the most urgent and and important
moral questions is why doesn't everyone
get to do that and how can we change the
world such that more people do last week
I was in Africa I was in countries
including Senegal and Ethiopia and
Rwanda and those countries are obviously
far less wealthy than the US and the
people there have far less opportunity
and their lives are far less comfortable
and and so I think there's there's a
real moral question what can we do to
put them on a on an equal footing with
us and indeed how can we raise the water
line for all of us such that you know
while our lives are amazing compared to
the people who lived you know before us
you know there's still tons of terrible
things that happen you know people die
of cancer and people die of you know
death caused by pollution and you know
while some people in society today get
you know fantastic education and have
the good fortune to have you know great
colleagues and meaningful work you know
a lot of people don't etcetera etc and
so I see kind of economics and economic
history as being really a kind of moral
anthropology and sort of cultural
analysis and structural analysis of well
how do we solve this
centrally foundationally this question
that that really takes primacy mm-hmm
and if you if I want a thin slice this a
little bit and dig dig on this because
it's it's something that I've thought a
lot about without any concrete
conclusions and I've bounced around
quite a bit and I'll explain what I mean
by that so did the the question that
I'll want to ask but I'll give some some
background on my personal experience is
for if if we are using a term like
economic progress or economic prosperity
what the component pieces are of that
that have the the greatest benefits and
the fewest side effects and the reason I
phrase it that way is I've I've also
spent some time in Africa not
not certainly I would I would doubt in
as many countries as you have but if
time in Kenya and spent time in Ethiopia
and in Ethiopia was mostly in the tiga
die region in some very very poor areas
and I was chatting with a lot of the
folks we interacted with those who those
who spoke English or those with whom I
could communicate through translator and
something that's one thing that struck
me in Ethiopia was how much people
smiled yes now that doesn't mean they
don't need clean drinking water does not
mean they wouldn't benefit from Footwear
and some instances there are all sorts
of there are all sorts of not just
comforts but necessities and
infrastructure that would almost
certainly have tremendous upside and
benefits with very few downside
that's possibilities and I was talking
to some people who lived in Tegan I
about how happy if the open seemed to be
and I heard on several occasions it
wasn't just one these are in in
different locations
people say oh yeah people are really
happy until they get TV and I and I
asked him why that was and they said
well once we get TV we they didn't use
these words exactly but in effect once
we can see the Kardashians and all of
the amazing things and toys and cars and
and fashion options that all these other
people have we become dissatisfied with
where we are and what we have so that
kind of stuck with me and I didn't have
a resolution to that necessarily but how
do how do you how do you think about
which components you're trying to solve
for or itemize for so I think happiness
is certainly have a a tricky measure
right and as you say this kind of this
sort of sociological and I'm kind of
comparative version of it and you know
the phenomenon is seen we're kind of to
some degree I guess this is another
version or another way of saying what
you just alluded to which is the kind of
the happiness you have with your level
of wealth is kind of a function of the
wealth of those around you and so if you
find out about more you know people who
are above you and some income table that
that might actually kind of depress your
your happiness slightly however it's
also kind of pretty robustly the case
that you know there are some things that
are just kind of absolute inputs into
happiness and that you know kind of your
health or chronic pain or whether your
kids die or not or whatever you know
these really do matter right and yeah I
think you know in the example of
Ethiopia I mean while kind of on the one
hand I think you know as I guess you saw
you know it's not like you know this is
a country where sort of everyone is sort
of in the perpetual depths of despair it
does rank in the in the bottom half of
sort of you know global happiness
surveys and actually max roser has this
you know he does a lot of kind of a data
visualization around kind of development
economics and he has this wonderful
visualization this kind of scatter plot
of happiness against kind of per capita
income and sure enough what you see is
it's certainly not a you know a perfect
correlation there are all these other
factors would be kind of cultural
effects or these again comparative
questions and so on but broadly speaking
the correlation really is very very
strong and so I guess another version of
be the kind of complexity you're getting
at is when you look at this kind of
these intertemporal comparisons when you
sort of look back at how people how
happy they reported themselves as being
you know 60 years ago you know obviously
they had kind of you know inferior
health outcomes or they didn't have as
many leisure options or they couldn't
travel as much or whatever so you know
they're kind of lives and some objective
level were worse but you know their
happiness scores aren't that bad because
you know I guess you know on some of
them they kind of didn't know what
missing but I see that as more being a
more being something that's tricky about
happiness surveys then something about
kind of fun
mental human wellbeing in that if I like
the fact that our baseline shifts as we
realize that better is possible does not
mean that the the gains are illusory and
if you know if if half of my kids died
but I still scored myself as being
pretty happy because I didn't even
realize that some you know that not
having that happened it was even an
option you know I I such that when that
problem was solved my kind of
self-reported level didn't change that
much as I you know adjusted to the new
normal I don't think that means that
that gain that improvement is not very
very real oh sure totally and and I was
no no that's what you're saying I know I
think I think yeah the core point you're
making it about kind of complexity to
happen to surveys I think is 100 percent
right yeah it's it's very very slippery
and yes she's not a scott scott
alexander slice our codex has a really
good blog post about just like the the
trickiness of these kind of happiness
surveys where I think kind of the core
message and data from them is is kind of
correct but but kind of a lot of
specific I think interpretations and
kind of comparisons going to make are a
little bit fraught oh yeah absolutely I
mean it not to I don't want to cast
aspersions on all social sciences or
anything like that a lot of it gets very
squishy and it's so finely multivariate
when you're trying to assess something
like this in the field that even the
definitions by which the absolute laser
surveys are being conducted get very
very subjective and course I was looking
at a recent National Geographic I
suppose I would call it a poll it was
reasonably well constructed for what I
could tell to try to assess the happiest
places on earth and what I found
striking about it was and was was not
necessarily of the some of the the
frontrunners although I did find how
different they were interesting in the
sense that you have let's say Denmark
see Singapore which is particularly
interesting because it's
brand-new in a lot of respects it was
kind of a grant experiment and Costa
Rica very different places what I what I
found striking was that Bhutan which is
talked about all the time as among for
lack of a better term kind of hippie
new-age circles as being very
forward-thinking because they focus on
what was a gross national happiness of
GDP it is in fact one of the most
unhappy places and that something like
Gross National Happiness can be used as
kind of a don't look at this thing in
front of you look over here because
we're focusing yeah it can be looked it
can be used as a distracting factor from
some of the things that are actually
quantifiably bad yes so there's that
what have you found I mean in so we've
talked about the I suppose the certain
aspects of the wide divergence of
economic prosperity across the world my
my question would then be now what right
what are what are the levers to pull
what actually matters I mean there are a
lot of people squandering a lot of
attention and energy trying to fix this
in a thousand ways 900 of which probably
aren't going to amount to much what are
the what are the Archimedes levers in
right in a situation like this well I
guess the the first thing I'd say is I
think that questions you just asked is
the big question I think we should all
be obsessed with like I think you know
that I think you should ask every guest
that question I think people should be
people in positions of influence or or
where they can have you know great
impact like they should be obsessed with
it it is the it's it is an issue of true
moral importance I don't think there's
going to be any silver bullets and kind
of panaceas
and I mean obviously stripe is kind of
you know one iron in that fire
where with stripe you know we we hope to
contribute from our mission as to grow
the GDP of the internationally around
economic growth and like on some level
you know that sounds pretty arcane I
don't think there are many other
companies that sort of our you know if
framing their mission rather to GDP but
I mean it really does get back to this
this idea we've been discussing where I
think that's actually like a very urgent
cause I think I think roughly speaking
you can sort of break it down in two
ways there's kind of actually maybe
maybe three ways where there's kind of
how do you raise the level of countries
that are kind of behind the frontier so
emerging markets developing countries
how do you raise them to kind of where
we are today and there were these kind
of tantalizing examples that like that
is actually possible and so you look
good
you mentioned Singapore you look at Hong
Kong Taiwan South Korea to some degree
Vietnam of course China though China
slows quite a ways to go but but I mean
through these amazing examples of
countries that have nearly transformed
themselves in remarkably short periods
of time in South Korea is perhaps kind
of the best example just in terms of the
magnitude of the change and like just a
couple of decades and so you know we
might think like perhaps if you if you
look at Africa and kind of know other
countries existed you might say well
just inevitably it takes centuries for
this catch-up to happen and you know
maybe we can kind of accelerate it a
little bit but like you know there's
there's no way this can happen overnight
that's empirically not true we have
these examples of countries in which it
happened you know in a kind of a grand
arc of history sense it happened
essentially overnight and so what is it
about South Korea that kind of made that
possible and can we enact the same
transformation in in Egypt or in
Ethiopia so I think that's kind of one
dimensions the question I think the
other dimension is how do we how do we
advance at the frontier and so if you
think about in Western Europe or North
America or Singapore Japan whatever how
do we and we make
here and I think so much of that is how
do we how do we enable new things to
happen how do we have new technology get
deployed how do we have entrepreneurs
start more companies how do we unleash
the potential of more people who want to
do more weird things how to make sure
that when somebody spots an opportunity
for improvement that doesn't get kind of
squished by the kind of you know
stultifying sort of deceleration of the
status quo how do we make sure that it
gets kind of encouraged and amplified
and again obviously kind of striped is
you know an effort in this space as
indeed to is is pioneer and the third
one is well how do we how do we just
generate new knowledge how do we you
know understand the world more deeply
and what is it you know intrinsically
possible so that you know we've more
buttons to push on the on the sort of on
the switchboard and so I kind of break
it down in those sort of three ways and
I think they're they're all kind of
quite different questions and all really
incredibly important I agree that they
are very important and I'd love to
revisit for a second if you have any
thoughts South Korea it's come up a few
times what what are some of the
observations you've made or things that
you think are interesting about South
Korea like the the anything app and any
specifics of what they've done well
ironically it's actually the it's the
richest country in the world by GDP that
I've not been to so so you know I caveat
my answer with sort of that having said
that there's actually a really good book
in this topic and called how Asia works
by a Joe Studwell I believe and
basically you try to answer kind of
exactly this question of while I you
know why did South Korea and Taiwan and
China and Vietnam and so forth why did
they diverge from Philippines and from
Indonesia and you know to a significant
degree from India
and and so forth and and basically the
answer he gives and he has kind of a
Marshall is kind of fairly compelling
evidence for it is is the following and
land reform protected but competitive
industrial and kind of export industries
and then third tight control over the
consumer credit sector and that office
he seems like a very kind of you know
arbitrary basket of things but he makes
a pretty strong case for it and you know
just to provide a little bit of color on
that like the idea is that kind of first
you want to make sure that people own
their own land so they can kind of farm
it more effectively they can kind of
reap the rewards the fruits of their own
labor and so that kind of gives you this
immediate bump in kind of national
Lincoln when people you know can sort of
invest in something they really owned
themselves the second thing is well most
of these countries have no kind of
meaningful you know export industries or
these kind of you know value added
export industries and so you kind of
want to eat you you encourage the the
creation like a national car company or
something which of course South Korea
successfully did or maybe do some
electronics manufacturing or whatever
and you want to subsidize that but you
do have to force them to compete
internationally because they just kind
of if you just protect them and they
just serve the domestic market you'll
just end up with a worse and lie
sufficient version of stuff that exists
in the rest of the world so you gotta
force them to compete and the third one
is you want to kind of restrain the
consumer credit industry search that
sort of rather than you know giving
credit to consumers to go and you know
spend it on leisure or whatever it is I
guess the consumers might choose to do
did you kind of direct all that towards
industrialization economic progress and
sort of catch-up growth with the rest of
the world and then once you catch up you
know then maybe you should kind of give
it to consumers because you know who
else are you going to give it to you've
reached the frontier but the thesis of
the book is that kind of reigning
attained in the development phases has
really served those countries well so
that is basically the prescription as Jo
again Studwell lays it out and I'm no
expert here but I've really spent quite
a bit of times that are trying to better
understand this question and it's
certainly the best cut that I've seen
another one that's kind of worth
mentioning as james Fallows word a piece
for the atlantic back in the 90s
called that called how the world works
but it's some title like that but if you
search kind of james Fallows
trade and if you include list this
german economist as a search term then
you'll find ish and it's again kind of
about it's basically about the the south
korea question great and i'll put all of
these links there been a few things that
have come up with the reference checks
required so for people listening I will
have my team check on all that stuff and
we'll put links into the show notes so
you'll be able to find those teamed up
log forward slash podcast on South Korea
just to add the a maybe ridiculous
sidebar another head scratcher about
South Korea is that for many years in
the last decade they have produced the
best break dancers in the world and
people who are curious to see what that
looks like can check out b-boy pocket or
some ridiculous footage and how that
came to be is also a gigantic mystery to
me but I'm hoping perhaps I can find
online there is a I want to say the
history of Japan in nine minutes
something like that on YouTube which
accomplishes that feat by omitting most
proper nouns particularly names of
people but it gives you a really nice
synopsis I'm gonna try to find something
similar for South Korea and put it in
the show notes so we have just a little
bit of time left what I would love to
talk about because this is something
that I I feel like I'm pretty good at
and this is decision making when I still
know there is a ton of room for
improvement and I in the process of
preparing for this conversation came
across a transcript of a conversation in
which you talked about increasing the
speed of decision making and it made me
think a little bit of i think is the
eisenhower matrix of sort of
prioritizing important but not timely
quadrant and so on but could you talk
about
it's making your your framework for
making decisions or or how you have
cultivated making faster decisions
because this is I think so important and
it's along with the the involvement of
now successful entrepreneurs as kids at
the dinner table the focus on making
fast decisions even if there's like a
10% or more error rate pops up a lot
like Reid Hoffman LinkedIn Fame another
kind of good example of that I would
love to hear you talk yeah talk us
through that because on a day to day
basis I know that's important and yet I
just I need a kind of methodical way to
practice it more if that makes sense yes
let me think for a second I think that I
actually think that decision-making
is probably a little bit overrated as as
kind of a question in that or an area of
study in that investors obviously this
is their job right and that's kind of
all they can do in some sense invest or
not and you know fine if they're you
know certain kinds investors get
actually help the companies they invest
in and so they have kind of other levers
at the disposal that come in some
simplified model it's like you know do
you click the button or not do you pull
a lever or not and I actually think that
kind of in our lives things rarely have
that character sometimes you have a true
binary decision right like do I go to
this college or that College do I take
this job offer or not and it sort of it
you know it's sort of an investing or
investment like decision but it's not
usually that and I think that the kind
of the question I would sort of
encourage people to kind of think more
about is how do I get to make better
decisions as in had like how do I make
sure the decisions I'm confronted with
end up being better like they you know
it's not like how should I choosing
option a and B how did I make sure that
both options a and
or as good as possible and it's also C D
and E and that those options are great
too and that's about sort of how do you
how do you explore the space to make
sure that you sort of actually well just
to kind of return to maybe the example
we just mentioned it's like you know do
I go to this college or that college
it's I mean there's also a sea there
which is well should I go to college or
it's you know should I should I become a
doctor or a dentist but you know maybe
the answer is that you know you should
you should become a biochemist and so
the the way I I find myself in
conversations people who are really
trying to push them it's less until how
do you make a decision and more about
how do you Joel to yourself out of that
kind of particular kind of furrows that
you're in and realize the possibility
space and the world is just so much
bigger than perhaps people are thinking
about it that's so I mean how does all
this happens to me they could have your
horizons narrow you get stuck in your
existing models you kind of get used to
conceiving of the world and the options
in front of you in a particular way and
it's more about how do you repeatedly
pull yourself out of that how do you do
that other questions you ask are there
any thinks I think certain certain
people are great at this like I have a
friend Michael Nielson and what was the
last name Nielsen and I Els en and he's
just exceptionally good at sort of you
know you're sort of you know thinking
well should I go up or down and he's
just great it's sort of pointing out all
the different ways in which you could go
sideways and I was like or you know
you're you're sort of living in flatland
on this kind of two-dimensional plane
and he points out maybe you could go up
and and so I guess the best yeah the the
best ways that I found our sort of
particular people people who just sort
of seemed to think laterally and kind of
I guess in my head they're kind of
thinking sideways and I think the second
best way is exposing yourself to kind of
more perspective and ideas you know in
all the ways we kind of already
discussed but I think finding the people
who just think a bit divergently the
returns are really high and I think
having that sort of little Board of
Directors around you that's kind of an
imperfect analogy because it's not like
there's a specific set for me I kind of
tend to go to different kinds of people
for different kinds of issues and it's
not like they actually of any formal
power obviously but just kind of that
notion of there being these sources of
perspective that are quite different to
you I think that's I think it's just
really very powerful I think valuing
those people and and and building those
relationships really pays off mm-hmm
there's there's a this you mentioning
that the peer group or virtual or real
board of directors with divergent
thought processes made me think of a
book that really helped me a long time
I've been meaning to revisit it but it's
actually a combination of two books and
I don't know how well these would age if
I were to pick them up now for where I
am but I would honestly by 15 or 20
years ago found them very very helpful
Edward de Bono is the author there's one
book I want to say it's lateral thinking
the other was something along the lines
of the the six thinking hats and the the
the conceit or the premise behind the
latter is that you create a virtual
table of advisers who represent
different person different extreme
perspective rights you might have a
pessimist you might have the innovator
you might have the fill in the blank and
there are a set of questions and
priorities and each of those have so you
run your situation through the lens of
each of those thinking hats and I found
that tremendously valuable for yes as
you put it getting out of flatland well
and the amazing thing is well I I read
about this study I have not confer
whether or not it has replicated but the
idea that people can improve their own
decision-making by simply choosing other
people I mean be exactly along the lines
but you just said and imagining what
they would say like specific other
people imagining what they would say and
then averaging over the responses but
it's like a really amazing fact because
of course this is all occurring in your
own head and so the idea that by kind of
just simulating other people and then
again can approach that this kind of
averaging computation over the responses
so that's easy better is really like a
pretty trippy thought and yet I mean it
kind of makes sense to you right because
you you can actually for certain people
predict I think with relatively good
accuracy what they're likely to say
that's kind of a way of getting out of
your own biases totally and in fact I
haven't done the averaging of responses
but I do have a number of friends who
have very well developed characteristics
I would like to develop more myself and
as one of them who comes to mind is Matt
Mullenweg the that's great sees amazing
guy CEO of a company called automatic ma
GT automatic if people can put the two
together now so Matt Mullenweg automatic
in any case brilliant guy not to be
confused with automatic but Matt
Mullenweg Matic is way way way more
successful than automatic so Matt Matt
Mullenweg is one of the calmest people
on average I've ever met and this is
particularly noticeable when he is going
through circumstances or encountering
business situations or personal
situations that would elicit a really
strong emotional response from most
people i know even i achieving people
hmm so I very often when I am feel
myself on the verge of getting spun up
yeah about a given situation will ask
myself what would Matt say because I've
had him talk me off the ledge so many
times
away from making rash ultimately would
have been really bad decisions often
some type of quick emotional response -
yes who knows what it could have been
anything and since I have found that
really useful and I've done that also
with people like Richard Fineman for
instance yes surely you think it's well
surely you're joking mr. five favorite
books of all time so it does not it does
not have to be someone you know in a
direct national sense but it helps if it
is someone who you have you feel you
know well right yeah and so I'm glad you
mentioned that because I've personally
used that mat for whatever reason I
suppose for many reasons tends to be
when I go to a lot because I wouldn't
say that calmness is always my defining
strong suit ya know I think having those
that pantheon of people both kind of
people you actually know and then sort
of you know people you know from afar
and maybe they're living maybe they're
dead and he's just super powerful and I
guess there's something about kind of us
as humans where were sort of uniquely
well adapted to being influenced by and
understanding other humans and so sort
of rather than I think thinking about
sort of decision making purely this kind
of abstract science but actually
embracing the fact that it has this kind
of deeply human character to it and you
know you can really kind of use that to
your advantage and you know it I'm sure
many I know many guests in the show have
talked about the importance of kind of
being deliberate and intentional and
kind of selecting your pure group and
the people who influenced you as an you
know what one thing you can do is you
can sort of try to make sure the people
around you don't influence you too much
and that you kind of are you know truly
original and coming up with their own
thoughts and so on or you can embrace
the fact that they do and they
inevitably will and just be careful
about who they are and try to make sure
they'll shape you in sort of ways and
directions as you want to be shaped
and I think that's both more effective
but also nice get more fulfilling way to
go about it and I I want to confess also
that I thought when you were talking
about binary decisions first whether it
be investing or say College where I
thought you might go which which I'm
glad you didn't because now we have more
to discuss is that there are many
decisions where you cannot possibly make
an informed right decision based on
complete information yeah and and that's
part of the reason why I find Eisenhower
very interesting to study is that yet a
lot of military experience in which case
you cannot you do not have the luxury of
taking forever to gather information to
make a decision and in many cases you
you the only way you can have more
complete information is to make what
might be yes
the wrong decision and then and then
course correct yeah exactly this is back
to this point I think of you're dead
right - kind of flank this and I think
it's back to this idea that just try to
get better try to get yourself into a
position in which you can make a better
decision and one way you can do that is
by kind of exploring for more options
right now another way you can do that is
just make the decision and like remake
it if you have to because that can the
remaking of us can often be a better
decision because you'll have much better
information once it's augmented with or
once you have the kind of additional
information that hey this branch really
does not look promising and I know that
because I tried it for you know two
months and again I think another way in
which the the kind of framework of sort
of optimizing decision-making can be
kind of a little bit harmful is and it
sort of characterizes or I guess it
focuses on the locus of the decision
itself whereas who cares you don't
necessarily need to be sort of that good
at decision making if you sort of get
really good at remaking the decisions
when and as necessary you know you you
might you mentioned that you know I fly
you know both John and I have been
flying for more than 10 years and you
know when you're when you're flying a
landing you're always off
tract always off track and you know if
you if there was a big discussion of
like how do you make sure that you get
established I'm like precisely the right
polite slope when you start you know I
don't think that really be that
productive I think we sort of pretty
frustrating instead it's all about like
the constant feedback and and course and
error correction and I think that's kind
of as a general matter a better model
for life and that even a lot of the
decisions that look pretty trapdoor may
not necessarily be there's a really good
book that I very highly recommend called
the inner game of tennis kind of Timothy
Timothy goal yeah exactly and you know
obviously one of the kind of general
messages of that book is that so much of
doing things well is about being really
good at seeing just what is happening
and kind of then sort of training your
conscious and subconscious to kind of
make the requisite Corrections and that
intuition really resonates with me I'm
so glad you mentioned that
and it it's reinforced I think a
directional change for me or not not
really it's not a directional change
it's a it's like reformatting of the
thinking about the problem right because
you could have the best solutions
imaginable for the wrong problems and
you're not going to get where you want
to go in my case exactly I think I
focused excessively on getting better at
decision-making without really refining
that to say that you know perhaps the
better question to ask is how can I get
better at or better could mean faster
develop more confidence in experimenting
very quickly and then undoing or redoing
the discussion because that is that is
you know for instance I've in the last
year focused on getting very good at
renegotiating commitments which I think
we're long time philosophically or
morally I'm just objected to it until I
realized that all of the people I know
and say all but most who are kind of
Paragons of execution will occasionally
just say [ __ ] I bit off more than I can
chew I need to go back and
negotiate some of these I need to go
back and have uncomfortable
conversations and wipe my calendar of
the handful of things that I committed
to six months ago because it just does I
have more information now it does not
make yes yep yep yep and all the kind of
hyperbolic discounting that we engage in
with regard to our future selves and
over commitments didn't see you and all
the rest and I I think also well there's
another I think fabulous book that kind
of touches on some of this and the art
of doing science and during by Richard
Hamming yeah you might Harbor science
and engineering yes that's right and the
last chapter especially I mean the whole
book to some degree but especially the
last chapter is I think really
applicable to and relevant to really
almost anyone the last chapter is called
you and your research actually have a
talk that I'm sure a lot of people
listen to the show have have previously
kind of read or heard but a hemming
worked at Bell Labs and he in the book
kind of often quotes insights John Tukey
this amazing guy who sort of also worked
at Bell Labs and is the sort of father
of of data visualization and like a lot
of kind of data visualizations and
analyses the kind of we're familiar with
the kind of we think of as being
standard there John Tukey actually
invented but there's this kind of two
key line that it's far better to have an
approximate answer to the right question
you know which is often vague then an
exact answer to the wrong question which
can always be made precise and again I
think this kind of gets back to the same
idea that it's kind of somehow a more
important to be kind of making the right
decisions to have the right options than
to be perfect at choosing between a
specific set of options right you know
what this is yeah that's that's really
aunt I would like to sit and digest that
myself and so it's probably just for
like recency bias for people listening a
good place to start wrapping up and I
know where we could go for hours more so
maybe we'll do another round sometime
but that'd be great
are there any partying recommendations
requests suggestions words of wisdom
anything at all
questions you'd like to pose to the
audience and a place where they can
respond or a way in which they can
respond anything at all that you'd like
to say before we before we wrap up I
mean I guess to whatever extent well I I
wrote in that list of advice that if
people around you don't think what
you're doing is sort of a bit strange
that maybe it's not strange enough and I
don't you should always be heating that
but I do often wish that people did more
did more strange things in service of or
in pursuit of real sort of long-term
economic and technological progress and
so you know that that's gonna figure out
how to help people to do more weird
strange and original things in service
of that is kind of that's that's my
particular goal trying to kind of arm
those upstarts and those misfits and you
know it's it but it's it's a very big
space and I would you know very
profoundly welcome more participants
pushing for that cause hear hear
and people can give a way of hello on
Twitter at Patrick see.yes sake and by
the way I think your podcast is is a
fabulous effort in this direction
thanks so much that that really means a
lot and that's certainly a hope of mine
I mean that it that is a hope of mine I
I so enjoy having these conversations
and it's it's opened so many doors for
me in terms of my own thinking and
questioning so many of my own
assumptions that I hope cumulatively
that it does help nudge things into a
more positive direction along the lines
that you mentioned so I appreciate you
saying that well you know I won't you
know bore you or flatter you with with
you know with praise here but but I I
think I mean it's my perspective
and I listen to a lot of podcasts that
that there's kind of a lineage of of
podcasts that can kind of be traced back
to this show and that there's a model
that you prototyped and and of the
continue to implement that you know now
a lot of other podcasts are kind of
somehow you know a different version of
which you know what which I'm excited
about because hopefully they'll they'll
do an even better job and I've been so
excited to see certainly Jocko willing
run off and create his entire empire
then you have Cal fuss Minh and right-t
it Peter Tia and others it's it's it's
really fun and Hamilton Morris I'm
waiting I'm waiting for your podcast
Hamilton to as our thousand people right
and and you know these aren't
competitive in the sense that you know
and you know Robinson Crusoe was kind of
one of the first novels and you know it
turns out that was a big space and it
was it was not a bad thing when more
novelists came along and so kind of
similarly I actually think that sort of
I'm not even sure where the podcast
space is the podcast space per se it's
more the sort of the the the serious
in-depth long-form X exploration but
it's even though that obviously is kind
of way bigger now than it was five years
ago it still seems to me that it's it's
actually so quite early
oh it's so early I agree it's it's
really really early I had people tell me
when I was contemplating starting a
podcast that the ship had already sailed
I mean it's a pretty smart people that
with a lot of experience and I were
telling me then that the ship itself and
I'm telling anyone who's considering
starting a podcast now that it's not
even close the ship hasn't even been
built this is one of them really
interesting and surprising things for
people to keep feeling and that spaces
are too late when in fact they're you
know you know not only not too late but
like still in the first 10% Marc
Andreessen talks about getting to
Silicon Valley and you know the early
90s and thinking man I'm too late and I
the the
and this kind of similar examples you
can point to and I mean we worried about
it with stripe obviously and and you
know yet yet we kind of came to realize
that actually you know the Internet as a
whole is still at the earliest innings
oh definitely yeah there's there's
always there's always I mean stripe is a
great example of this there's maybe
there's always a market for great and
and that is not dependent on creating or
shipping something today or this
afternoon there's always there's always
room for that well Patrick I meant that
Patrick I appreciate you taking the time
and thank you so much
this has been a lot of fun and for
everybody for everybody listening I will
put links to everything we discussed the
papers the books the site's some of the
folks on Twitter all these things in the
show notes which you can find at tim
doug forward slash podcast just search
patrick or call us and and this episode
will come right up you can scroll down
to find it and until next time thank you
for listening
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me and
would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every Friday and that provides a
little morsel of fun for the weekend and
five bullet Friday is a very short email
where I share the coolest things I've
found or that I've been pondering over
the week that could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek calm all
the spell out and just drop in your
email and you'll get the very next one
and if you sign up I hope you enjoy it
I get asked all the time if you could
only use one supplement what would it be
my answer is inevitably athletic greens
it is your all-in-one nutritional
insurance I recommended it in the 4-hour
body did not get paid for that and I
travel with it too boy getting sick I
take it in the mornings to ensure
optimal performance it just covers all
my bases if I can't get what I need
through whole food meals throughout the
rest of the day if you want to give
athletic greens to try they are offering
a free 20 count travel pack for
first-time users I always travel with at
least three or four of these this
represents a 100 ala value so if you buy
athletic greens you get an extra $100 in
free product
so check it out athletic greens dot-com
forward slash Tim again that's athletic
greens dot-com forward slash Tim for
your free travel pack with any purchase
this episode is brought to you by
99designs 99designs is the global
creative platform that makes it easy for
designers and clients to work together
from logos to apps packaging to books
99designs
is the go-to design resource for any
budget I've used 99designs
for many many years now I've used them
for book covers for instance mock-ups
for the 4-hour body which went on to
become a number one York Times best
seller illustrations for my multi-volume
the Tao of Seneca and other graphic
design projects and I've been really
impressed by the quality of their
designers and the designs that I've
ended up using most recently I use 99
designs to update the illustrations and
layouts of my five morning rituals eBook
this covers my most consistent morning
routines and rituals and I offer that as
an incentive for people to sign up for
my newsletter so this is a PDF bonus
that acts as a carrot to increase the
number of email subscribers the
illustrations inside are gorgeous and I
loved working with the designer who
selected for the project so you can
check it out take a look at that at 99
designs com4 slash Tim that's the number
99 designs com forward slash Tim and you
can see exactly
what I'm talking about with a real-world
example of what has come out of work
with them nunya and designs designer
search tool connects you directly with
one designer based on the design
category or an industry specialization
style skill level availability and more
so you can really check all the boxes
that you need and see who matches up or
you can start a contest and that means
you invite the entire community to take
a shot at your project then you pick
your favorite right now you guys my
listeners that is can receive a free $99
upgrade on your first design contest so
check it out to see what it looks like
to get your first free upgrade please
visit 99 designs conference on Tim and
click on the link in the landing page so
again check it out 99 designs comm
forward slash temp
you
you